for a professional tattooist Martin his
art is his life a life that's also been
touched by mental health issues his
autism went undiagnosed throughout his
school career and during the ten years
he spent in the Army serving in Bosnia
and in Iraq twice he is happy with the
talents his condition has bestowed on
him but admits it can make day-to-day
life pretty tough
it's harder see it's a psycho tomb it's
a blocky candle like an invisible force
for you lot to stop you from from doing
certain things and I think that's
probably the worst worse at spreading
luck and that can become like darker
times especially when it's someone saw
similar anything why can't I just do
that and I could be the worst part when
Martin feels the need to talk he prefers
the barber's chair to the psychiatrist's
couch here he can share his thoughts and
feelings with Sam Sam moved to Newcastle
to help with his own mental health now
he's part of the Lyons barber collective
a charity designed to help tackle
depression and suicide in men every time
they come like the third haircut bought
a third haircut you'll be amazed at what
they're actually open up about and then
they'll come back and say off I've now
taken action so again is it's just
providing that support and being an ear
to listen to for them to take that first
step to make a change recent figures
from the Samaritans show that men are
three times more likely to die by
suicide than women in 2017 4382 men took
their own lives compared to 1439 women
middle-aged men are the most at risk
the suicide rate amongst 45 to 49 year
old males was twenty four point eight
per 100,000 suicide stats are so high
for men because in all honesty
traditionally we're not that great at
talking about our staff you know we're
not that great opening up women will
have a support network or even a series
of support network so they go to four
different things men don't feel
comfortable traditionally doing that
it's good to have to know that you're
not the only person that's won through
certain things you know like back when I
was younger there wasn't that many
people it could be all blue
you just deemed as weak you know what I
mean or something like that so now like
you even talk about stuff it's a lot
better you know the collective has a
scheme called barber talked where
stylists like Sam can be trained in how
to recognize where there may be a
problem and to talk listen and signpost
their clients to help help every man
it's certain praise the Lord Sky News
gets